Vicki is in Phoenix hi Vicki how are you
I'm good how are you Dave
better than I deserve what's up Dave I
have a question i am i want to say i am
on baby step number four have the
emergency fund on there my question to
you is I'm kind of in a bind I don't
know to start paperwork on my husband's
citizenship or do I start
or do I dump that money into starting to
purchase the house because I haven't
started that yet well which one would
you rather have one boat I don't know
what I know which one do you want first
I would probably get the citizenship out
of the way personally correct and then
and then I would be saving up for a
house and if you want to put your
retirement on hold on baby step four
temporarily till you knock out those two
rather big expenses well then that's
okay it's a temporary thing we call it
baby step 3b when you're saving up for a
house that sometimes people put their
retirement on hold a little bit until
they save up a downpayment after they
finish their emergency fund and are debt
free
yeah well I kind of am forced to put
money towards my retirement only because
it's taken out I'm employed with the
state so it's an automatic 15 percent
that needs to go towards my retirement
you can't stop that no that that gets
taken out of my growth no Matt no matter
what no matter what okay well you don't
have a choice then right so you know now
you're saving you know you're saving
first to take care of the citizenship
issue and then you're saving like crazy
to take care of the house okay not
that's order I would do it in but if you
have a reason to do it otherwise I just
I don't think we put a house in front of
his citizenship right I just wasn't sure
because I got to step number four and I
I saw that step number two was pay off
all your debt except the house and I
when I got to step number four I'm like
wait a minute I don't have a house to
pay off in step number six you know yeah
I got you I got you and you will have
and you'll be you know you'll be right
on track know do you have a copy of the
book the Total Money Makeover
I do not okay it explains all of that
let me give you a copy of it
I'll have Kelly ship that out to you so
hold on I'll have her pick up I'll give
that to you as a gift we appreciate you
listening in Phoenix